при в'їзді дає суму і пак і 10 тисяч
євро на псидака роботи в гаю та наші їх
може конфіскувати та
єврокомісія пропоную до золота і такого
купити кувата і менше суму легше було
кнаппе дозор ще простіше примарними для
фінансування тероризму та тещини все
сайкса за дикою новим провалом
отриманим у цього бік ми
банки в скира hunky підозрюваних але про
витрати до лірики плану та теракт в одні
скроєні з матір ніби заморозженные у
продавця максимум 48 поставити ще один
закордонний захист хто тут у рушницю we
наказу з передплаченої кредитної
карткою на суми 150 євро мусатом
через свічку ту свою особу національні
службу bespeco матовий доступ до даних
всіх наших служб у мишах є доступ нею
форматі відривати такий європейський
агентство про гордон та
то берегової оборони фронт x та європол
законопроекті єврокомісії ще моя
пляшка хвиля україна ми членом
євросоюзу
а також європарламентом